[Music]
this is all a flashback for me in the
sense that I was in an artist collective
in New York back in the 60s called
us Co and we made a big deal about
paying close attention to engineers and
scientists and making a part of the work
that we were doing and all that cool
stuff as if we were inventing that and
the reality is that art and technology
being in each other's armpits for a long
time from Leonardo on the Media Lab was
basically where I worked for a while is
based on the idea of jamming art and
technology together Burning Man is based
on the idea of throwing art and
Technology out in the desert and raining
on them seeing what happens and so that
these guys have gone to screaming edges
of both what's going on with our and
what's going on with specifically web
technology is in keeping with a very
long tradition and I guess that's part
of that makes this along now event
artists have embodied as they say
long-term unconscious of humanity and
they probe as McLuhan pointed out into
the future harder and faster and smarter
than anybody so please welcome Jon
Polito as Jolene bleh
[Music]
all right
good enough Thank You Stuart and we're
very excited to be here Jolene and I
we're going to go in a direction
hopefully the future has all long now
projects seem to eventually emphasis on
eventually that might be a little
different from what you're used to in
the sense that we're going to talk about
art on the edge but with a particular
slant about our opinions of art on the
edge and why it's on the edge why we
need it on the edge and what it does for
us
Jolene if you want to get started it's
really a pleasure to be here speaking
with you in this particular context
along now and we tend to be thinking
about the future and along now and I'm
gonna spend a moment talking a little
bit about the past because the long then
is also important to I'm going to revert
back to ceremony which is where I come
from right now and I'm going to say Who
I am where I come from and to greet the
people of this place and the spirits of
this place which is a ceremony from the
people that I'm from my people are
French and they're also Algonquin the
French people have been on this
continent in the Northeast for over 400
years or and the Algonquin of course
have been there for over 10,000 years
and so this is where I come from I'm on
the edge of two different cultures and
you will hear that a little bit in my
presentation today so I want you to know
something about where I come from I'm
also a mother with young children and
very interested in surviving the futures
in front of us and having them survive
in those futures so that's where I come
from and I also want to greet the
spirits who have been here for over
10,000 years and who to recognize that
we stand in a place that has had life
for that long today as we gather here to
speak in the home lands of the Ohlone
Acosta knowin people whose forebears
have lived here for at least 10,000
years our foreign technological cultures
have brought us in a very short time
period to Empire collapse and global
ecological catastrophe like many
previous moments in geological upheavals
and transformation we are perched on the
knife edge
between annihilation and survival like
the creatures of the Paleo Proterozoic
period when eukaryotes turned deadly
oxygen gas into the atmosphere of oxy
phobic life we must change or die our
question today is whether artists can
tip the balance towards survival we
believe John and I that with proper
support art is uniquely positioned to
push us out of the Cenozoic area era
that we currently inhabit into the eco
zoic era in which bottom-up networked
systems can help regenerate the life
that our inappropriate technology is so
easily trampled and superseded acting
along the patterns of nature found in
our own bodies specifically the
antibodies of our immune system art
appears to be one of our best
technologies for surviving peak oil
market crash and accelerating species
extinction but how does art do this in
thriving indigenous cultures all beings
including humans exercise this power in
euro-american cultures especially in
so-called democracies we nervously
narrow this privilege to artists still
we can recall many historical examples
of artists wielding this power Shelley
call poets the unacknowledged moral
legislators of their age pound call them
quote the antenna of the race but while
the pintubi of australia grant each
family the power and responsibility to
co-create the universe and each
generation as they resync their
songlines euro ethnic cultures have
rarely accorded artists direct influence
outside the galleries and museums
Jellico and Picasso had to be content
with painting representations of the
medusa or Guernica rather than taking
part in historical incidents or
generative creation
of the world in our age the death of the
artist and the slashing of public
funding for the Arts has narrowed that
vocation even more it's no wonder then
that many creators have abandoned the
term artists for more influential
vocations vito akan she of the Benetton
advertising campaign changed his job
description to designer and Brenda
Laurel the game designer some of you may
know changed her as to culture worker
while alexey shelygin told artists to
quote forget the very word a very word
and notion art and then there were the
countless artists who during the.com
boom gave up their unlikely quest for
fulfillment in the art world to join
what turned out to be just as unlikely
quest for fulfillment as creatives in
e-commerce and game companies as you can
see the West has been very good at
convincing its humans to give up their
own powers in favor of the machines both
industrial and corporate that can do the
work for them or tell them how to do it
of course the problem with handing over
your powers so readily can be measured
in a culture addicted to entertainment
caffeine alcohol and antidepressants a
culture that resigns itself to the
corporate persons ideology that humans
are unredeemable and destined to
exterminate themselves which for the
outset looks very good to the machines
that do not calculate their dependence
on us oops
in the meantime of course and outside
the fairytale of mass media indigenous
peoples local communities and Internet
artists are reclaiming their sovereignty
and their attendant creative powers
ingenuity erupting far from art studios
and galleries has started to take on a
function that's looking more like art
among the digital artists we survey in
our book at the edge of art creative
people are typing lines of self epic
self-replicating software they're
splicing genes at lab benches and
they're rigging makeshift Wi-Fi network
and they're in doing so reshaping our
culture's vision of itself although they
apply new techniques like polymerase
chain reactions in PHP mm-hmm they
choose not to subordinate their work to
the political and economic imperatives
governing their colleagues and
scientific or media industries instead
they wield these powerful tools and
might might best be described as an
artistic bent one whose influence
extends far beyond the conventional
confines of art leveraging the internet
to infiltrate stock markets to sway
court cases and to network bedrooms
note that with this reclaiming of
creative power comes an insistent on the
insistence on the full range of creative
power not satisfied with mere
representation this generation of
creative seeks real power in the world
the power to play the power to create
the power to challenge and subvert
real-world structures this is not
representation this is engagement or in
our terms execute ability this is the
real creative economy and it belongs to
the people not the corporations that
have always sought to colonize as
potential to enrich their current
versions of the East India Company
well the Pirates are back and like the
originals who were often escaped natives
and slaves they have come to reclaim
their full sovereignty so we talked a
little bit about we see arts purpose and
now we're going to talk a little bit
about how art goes about doing that
because how do you reclaim sovereignty
in the history that Julian described of
it basically being taken away from us
and specifically most creative people
are probably the people we should be
looking to to see how to do it we in the
book discuss lots of examples from game
art to autobiography from community
building to political design but today
we're going to focus on two particularly
potent symptoms of the powers wielded by
artists of the Internet age and you
see from their names of these symptoms
why plato was so keen on banishing poets
from his Republic the two powers are
perversion and execution so perversion
artists have always been perverse in
their way
right so Caravaggio paints the Virgin as
a prostitute on her deathbed hires a
prostitute as a model that's a pretty
perverse thing today we have Cristo
feely making Virgin Mary's out of
elephant dung but that's sort of a
perversity that's a you know purely kind
of print or sexual maybe and that's not
quite what we mean by perversion in our
book digital and genetic techniques give
artists the ability to automate
perversion so if you're scared by
regular perversion like Caravaggio then
you should really be scared about
automated perversion artists who wield
these tools can summon forth entire
universes of unlikely forms with a few
strands of DNA or a few strokes on the
keyboard of generative code one example
is John Simon's every icon now this is
an artwork that began in 9 2001 or 2002
Wow 1997 okay we can't see the top of
this it's still going on and if
computers last for the next hundred
trillion years it will still be going on
this is a very long now artwork it just
lasts a long time and the artwork is
very simple you can see it's been it's
the little boxes
shuffling this is an algorithm that will
actually generate every possible icon
that can be generated in a 32 by 32
squares so at one particular point your
face will flash by this or something
that looks like your face you might not
be there to see it but it will be there
if it can be represented in a 32 by 32
icon so this is one example of the very
strange and powerful kind of artwork an
artwork that can span huge amounts of
time assuming the technology can keep
pace with it so I also wanted to mention
a project by Jody some of you who have
familiar with artists on the internet
they're sort of
I don't know the dynamic duo or poster
children of the Internet age and they're
best known for projects that really kind
of screw around with you for example if
you go to OSS Jodee org you will see
something like this
this project really crashes your
computer so it's kind of scary to do
this in a presentation projector what
happened so this is actually rather old
projects from 1999 something along that
something something some of the late 90s
and we're fairly familiar with pop-up
ads by now but the artist got there
first they actually created a website
that creates these insanely manipulating
and and sort of proliferating pop-up
windows and if you ever try to close
them it's just impossible so reminds me
of that woman in Vermont who is facing
40 years in prison for for accidentally
launching a porn site while 12 year olds
were watching and being unable to click
all the pop-up windows or something
I should also say that Dirk pace Mons
who who is one of the Jody folks told
Jolene and I that his favorite
occupation when he goes to a new city is
to look for those Apple stores there's
great big white beautiful buildings
where you're basically walking in a
white cube with a row of you know 24
IMAX and he goes up to each one and of
course they've got you know internet
access they're back in watches while
this white cube becomes filled of these
crazy black ink black rectangles and
very soon afterward filled with Apple
tech people trying to figure out what
the hell happened to their Safari that's
the only way actually to get out of it
is to force quit so I will do that now
Gil Prado okay back to about this
project is that we get the sense like as
when we play video games that we somehow
are in control when we you know launch
our computers and our browsers and we
make the machines do what we want them
to do and I think Jody was really
interested in showing us that we don't
always have the kind of control that we
think we do and we we lose
well we get very nervous that whole
moment of who or what's in control and
the sort of waking up out of that trance
that we're in charge of what's happening
with our technology I think is really
important so okay so one other example a
little more in control perhaps but just
as as sort of a perverse in the sense of
being autumn people automate many
multiple strange kinds of forms that
kind of polymorphous perversity that
Freud talked about is Ken musgraves
planet Moho this is a those of you who
know that sometimes fractal algorithms
from mathematics are used to create for
example scenes and you know waves in the
Titanic or or mountaintops in an alien
space in movie Ken actually did this a
lot of the software Bryce that produces
that but he also for fun made a
essentially a Planet generator that
anyone could use and create these
planets on their own and it's really
nifty sort of interface that allows you
to to manipulate you know essentially
terraform your own world very quickly
and and with enormous potential for a
variety with basically operating on the
generative code of algorithms like
fractals and then he created a sort of
transporter so within the Moho world
universe you can basically transport to
each other's planets and everyone can
kind of create their own so that gives
you some sense of the of the kinds of of
tools that are available to artists in
the ways that they can generate forms
quickly sometimes as in the case of Ken
Musgrave they're operating just from
sort of you know some basic formulas in
the case of artist mark napier he just
works from any given web page and his
project is called the shredder which I
will launch I think here I have it okay
so one of the distinctions between these
two projects is that when you see Ken
musgraves work you don't know what's
under the hood you see the pretty
world's being formed and you see the
mountains changing and you see the skies
and you see the rivers forming but you
don't really know what's causing that
change you move a few buttons so he
knows because he's a programmer and he
knows what's going on behind the hood
mark Napier's project shredder shows us
what's going on on under the hood with
Internet webpage
so he basically takes a page and shreds
it and turns the web page inside out so
that you can actually see the HTML tags
the JavaScript the other things that are
behind this scene as some of you who go
to view source will see that anyway but
those of you who don't can can see some
of it in mark Napier's pages my students
inspired by this work actually create
narratives in which you're going through
a web page and reading a narrative and
at one point one of the clues or one of
the pieces of the story is actually in
the source code so you have to actually
go into the source code to get part of
the story part of the narrative so my
students are actually learning to get
under the hood and and find out where
the coding is happening which is I think
where the real generative power for this
kind of art is happening so this is the
just long now site of course and let's
shred it let's shred it so I'm just
typing type in any bookmark you went and
whoa what's going on okay so what you
see now is the long now website turned
inside out so what was big is small what
was small is big what was hidden was
shown and what was shown is hidden and
this is a fairly not that difficult to
do internet art isn't always about like
achieving something that's technically
very difficult but it's lots of fun
because you can mess around with
people's pages and see all kinds of
things they didn't intend every time you
shred the site that looks differently so
again it's not so much making a single
image as well as much as making a way of
making multiple images now actually Mary
Flannigan has an interesting version of
this which can play on your own computer
on your own hard drive and actually
turns that inside out as well and she
thinks of it as the unconscious of the
not so much the unconscious of the
machine but some kind of unconscious
that the user has put there because what
happens is it starts to mix your
photographs with the songs that you
listen to with your email to your cousin
or your mother or your old lover and
that comes up next to a song about you
know and so all these things start to
mix up in this director kind of file and
so she's sort of revealing all those
things you know for the computer what
Freud revealed in his sort of
psychoanalysis session so what's
underneath there that gets hidden and
repressed and put away and and what does
it feel like when it comes back up to
the surface and how do our machines
begin to represent who we are and what
does it mean to
under there and see so if you're
interested in that Mary Flanagan's phage
is something to look at as well Mary
Flanagan comm is where you can find her
work Fla
na gan Flanagan okay so the other
symptom we were going to talk about for
art apart from perversion is execution
and execution in this sense is a potent
technique for distributing work if
perversion is the 21st century artists
most potent technique for creating new
forms to execute of course is what we
see in computers when you're running a
program you know you launch a word
processor or spreadsheet but the mean
can the term can be extended to mean
triggering an existing system to
discharge a task that changes the state
of the system okay that's a really like
general boring definition but what
executable art does is hijack today's
computational systems legal systems
economic systems and in those networks
it propagates outside the studio or the
gallery to effect distant people and
events so in one example that you see in
the image of upper right Joe Davis and
biotech artists hijacks the reproductive
system of E coli the bacteria he draws a
picture in its DNA and then he unleashes
this info gene basically an image
embedded in DNA encoded in DNA I should
say into the natural ecosystem the
yes-men do something different
how many people here have heard of the
yes-men have you seen the yes-man video
or just heard about them yeah they do
some high-class jinx they started off on
the art Marc site and somebody asked
them to do a website they had got the
domain name George W Bush GW Bush comm
and apparently the Bush campaign hadn't
got that yet this was before the
election so they got the site and they
reproduced it with a few slight changes
and the of course Bush people got very
upset and they sent cease
desist and they told me to take it down
and in dadada and they refused to so of
course reporters came on the scene and
they asked Bush what he thought about
this and for some of you who've seen
their movie Bush actually responds to
this and says well these are garbage men
they're just doing garbage and when he's
pushed about whether or not they have
the right to do this online he says well
there ought to be limits to freedom
that's when he actually made his famous
statement there ought to be limits to
freedom in response to reporters asking
questions about the yes-men website so
so and they've done a number of
different pranks and this is one of them
that I've just showed my students the
other day they put up a Dow ethics webs
douwe ethics calm Dow had their own
website but they forgot Dow ethics
because of course they don't think about
ethics so the yes men pulled it up and
they they did a prank on the anniversary
of the Bhopal catastrophe and they
because they had a doll with its website
I think it's MSNBC got in touch with up
and did an interview with them and
during the interview they basically
apologized for the Bhopal incident and
said that they were going to pay all the
reparations for all of the injured in
this and this went on MSNBC it was
broadcast worldwide everybody saw it
and of course Dow was forced to then the
next day say well action well but first
thing that happens suppose the stock
went down like what for for billions of
dollar at four point two percent in
twenty three minutes the stock went down
after this came out so this is like huge
amounts of money and so what Dow was
forced to do is basically get back on
the airwaves and say we're sorry but we
don't apologize
for all that injury and we're sorry but
we don't take responsibility for what we
did and we're sorry that we're not gonna
do any of the things that our so called
air SATs representative said we would do
so this is the some of the pranks of the
of the yes Mitch it's also interesting
when you Jolene pointed this out to me
I've got the two websites side by side
and they added something to the yes my
students notice this when I put these
website this is the Dow ethics one and
on the Dow website very soon after the
dow ethics things started to happen they
have under quick links' you'll see the
first one is ethics that didn't use to
be there my aunt my students also said
oh yeah aren't those aren't those the
guy that do the hu the human element
campaigns they've seen him all over TV
and they said oh and now we know why
they're doing that human element
commercial stuff because they're trying
to recover from that real embarrassment
of not really caring about people so I
said yeah that's right that makes sense
so that's a bit of social hijacking and
also media hijacking what happens with
the yes-men is they use broad cat they
use network media to get out a kind of
trick identity then they jump on the
broadcast media and they announced their
their various they they basically do
what they call identity correction they
speak what should be spoken they say the
truth about what these people are
supposed to be saying so for example in
one case when they went to Australia
representing World Trade Organization
they actually disbanded the World Trade
Organization the Canadian Parliament
reported it in the middle of a
parliamentary session and they said they
were going to restart the World Trade
Organization along humanitarian lines
with all of the regulations of the Human
Rights Commission that the United
Nations had put together now of course
WTO had to do the same thing that Dow
Chemicals did which said no no we were
not really interested in doing that no
we really don't want human rights that's
not really what we're about so very
embarrassing so on the on the unless
that probe
well and a different angle of execute
ability quite literally the yes men of
course are are people who intervene in
politics even though they come from
perhaps an artistic background here's
someone who intervenes in art if you
will even though he comes from a very
different in this case a kind of
political politicized computer scientist
if there is such a thing there was a
case against the the hacker quarterly
2600 which some of you may know for
linking to code that allowed you to
decrypt a DVD so if you wanted to pirate
the Pirates of the Caribbean you'd use
this code called DCSS of course if you
wanted to back up your disc of Pirates
of the Caribbean so in case your kids
scratched it you wouldn't be out 20
bucks or 30 bucks you'd also have to use
this technology but the technology was
illegal at least circumventing the DC SS
was illegal under the delicious Digital
Millennium Copyright Act so linking to
that code was was a reason for the MPAA
to sue the hacker quarterly and in 2000
District Judge named Louis Kaplan issued
an injunction saying you have to stop
that you're you're linking to illegal
code now there was a computer scientist
named Dave turetsky out of Carnegie
Mellon who said you know something very
odd about this I'm a I'm a computer
scientist and I I write code all time
and for me code is a form of writing
it's a form of expression
it's an odd form of expression it's a
form of expression that a computer I
need a computer to help B interpret and
and express but I view it as a form of
expression anyway and when I was reading
judges Kaplan's decision he was struck
by the fact that the judge the defense
tried to say well you know freedom of
speech First Amendment and they said
judge said no no no no computer code is
not speech because it's executable
that's the difference and Trotsky said
gee I wonder if that's really true and
he did a series of experiments that were
basically are
mystic experiments in recreating that
DCSS code in a way that was not exactly
executable but sort of executable so it
he put a call out for people who were
interested in the issue activist
computer scientists artists whatever to
contribute variations on this DCSS code
and he got all kinds of versions in C
and Perl and so forth on the tiniest C
implementation that's kind of stuff that
you know computer science just get into
but he also got odd stuff like this this
is the DVD logo rendered as d CSS code
and if you look up really close you'll
see that's what it is but you know it's
it is a picture and pictures we know are
protected under freedom of expression so
does that qualify well there were plenty
of other examples including images that
weren't in ASCII so they weren't
immediately you could scan them in
character recognize them in which case
they'd be executable but ordinarily they
wouldn't be there were t-shirts there
was a haiku a beautiful haiku telling
you how to do it there's the t-shirt and
tie a dramatic reading well okay but if
you read the code is that executable a
Star Wars movie where the code moved
past the screen all the beginning of
Star Wars and anyway lots of lots of
great stuff and as a result on the this
gallery bite by he also kind of chose
this word in terms to suggest an
artistic context here it's a gallery of
CSSD scrappers so Jolin mentioned in the
introduction we have all these artists
are fleeing the word artists and calling
themselves designer and creative what a
hideous term created I'm the creative of
the dot-com company and there we have a
computer scientist saying no no no I've
got a gallery I'm an artist an in in so
doing argue
that there's a slippery slope between
executable code and you know sort of
quasi executable visual audio whatever
culture and as a consequence the that
when the court came to decision came up
in appeal I think of the Second Circuit
said no this guy turetsky is right he
came and he did his deposition and they
said we rule the court that code is a
form of expression it is analogous to
speech so here's an example where a
bunch of artworks in a gallery changed a
court case and you want to talk about
meta music yeah a few weeks ago I was
actually speaking with Johannes bogan
Huber who is the architect of the
European Constitution and doing that
conversation I said so what do you think
of etholon and he just flew out of his
seat and he said we have a lot of
trouble with echelon Ashkelon is
basically a kind of spy software that is
used by the UK USA agreement basically
Australia Canada New Zealand UK in the
United States and it's used in a number
of contexts said we have a big problem
with this because we're really worried
about spying on citizens we're really
worried about the power of this
technology spying on ordinary citizens
and so it turns out that the report that
was launched by the European Parliament
suggests that esalaam was capable and
I'm quoting now of interception and
content and inspection of telephone
calls fax email and other data traffic
globally through the interception of
communication including satellite
transmission public switched telephone
networks and microwave links this is a
sort of vast kind of citizen spy kind of
project so one of the ways that Internet
artists responded to this is to try to
span this net this this kind of software
so what you do is you you get a list of
all the code words so for example terror
nuclear bombs dynamite terror you know
Iraq there is some less obvious but
there's a whole list of code word so it
actually triggers the Echelon program to
start snoops you know snooping and
spying on you
they're also words like descent you know
dissident protest activism these are
also so um so what happened is they
thought they would find the whole list
of these code words and have lots and
lots of people start sending random
emails stuffed with all of these words
just to you know start a whole trail of
like red herrings all over the place and
if you if you jam it with enough false
signals and they won't be able to spy on
on on people who are using maybe to them
legitimately in a regular email about
their feminists course that's talking
about terrorism and you know Africa
whatever so yeah well that's that's what
happened in fact what happened what well
what happened is that this doesn't
really work very well because echelon
was a little bit smarter than that and
it wasn't just picking out certain words
it was picking up words in context it
turns out that I had to be the right
context the right grammar it had to
sound like what the program was designed
to sniff as real terror messages reals
you know spy networks whatever and so on
meta mute which was a magazine at the
time decided to launch a fiction writing
contest and they published the list of
code words or the sort of trigger words
and they said we're going to give a
thousand dollar prize to the short story
that includes the most number of code
words use the most number of times and
yet is a very interesting short story
and they actually published these short
stories in their meta mute a chillon
Edition which apparently was effective
enough to trigger all kinds of
interesting excitement by the Echelon
software so one of the things that you
can kind of take from this is that you
know literature has always held the
power to sway readers hearts and minds
but executable literature literature
that takes advantage of the networks
that are out there be they governmental
or or electronic can act directly on the
infrastructure of power woven into the
digital fabric of contemporary life
so if traditional literature cruises
faction through catharsis but leaves the
world's injustice is unchanged this is a
problem that Brecht and other people had
about contemporary art executable
literature produces satisfaction through
engagement through acting directly on
the world rather than standing back and
somehow kind of representing that so shy
going to antibody alright so a lot of
people have seen these powers of art and
said gee this is a lot like virus a
virus in fact in the case of the Jody
piece that almost took over my screen
they got booted from their ISP not long
after launching it because it said well
clearly you're forcing our viewers to
download a virus you know it shows how
much ISPs know about viruses but it also
shows a sense of the kind of terror that
sometimes accompanies people when they
see artists getting these newfound
powers and you know Andy Warhol said to
an updated his prediction that everyone
be famous for 15 minutes to the claim
that in 15 minutes everyone will be
famous I was a variation on it well
either claim seemed pretty unrealistic
1968 but in 2003 the advent of a Warhol
worm a virus that infected 90% of
vulnerable computers within 10 minutes
put that fantasy Within Reach
and people like all of your Otis Connie
who does very interesting ads for
companies that are nevertheless agitprop
sort of political issues describes his
work as a virus he says I'm an artist
art is a virus I'm a virus against you
know racism or whatever he's dealing
with like a cook more commercial world
and it's tempting viral metaphor makes
sense because viruses are perverse they
mutate and they're executable they
hijack the hosts means of replication to
further their own plural formation or
proliferation depending on whether
you're George Bush okay however viruses
originate outside a host organism and
they're interested in that host
surviving only long enough to enable
them to infect other hosts art on the
other hand originates inside the host
right and it's symbiotic with the larger
body its long-term survival and many
people would say its meaning depends on
the cultures that it either critiques or
celebrates so it's different it's not a
virus now of course a lot of artists
aren't necessarily comfortable with
being associated with society at least
with its status quo versions they want
to say no I'm off here I've got my beret
in my moustache and I'm different in
Western culture the feelings often
mutual but with we're rare exceptions
like you know Gables book burnings and
Stalin's poet purges no euro ethnic
society since Plato has really succeeded
in booting artists out altogether
they're their kind of social irritant to
fly in the grease but they're part of
culture along with the village idiots
criminals used-car salesmen and
presidents artists and unruly pesky
troubling symbian and that's because
it's tasks like the tasks of the Shaymin
is to serve as a diversity agent to
alert us to other nests and that other
nests can be both a danger and an
opportunity to do this well like the
Shaymin the artist must scout what is
unfamiliar court what is foreign and
engage what is not yet recognized
that's a daunting task it's one for
which euro ethnic cultures don't really
offer an obvious model the best metaphor
for arts contemporary role may be a
microbe but one internal rather than
external the antibody now why do I think
that antibodies are like viruses I mean
are like art well the job of an antibody
is to keep up with viruses so it's not
surprising that anybody share many of
the same powers as viruses including
perversion and execution
what are antibodies again their proteins
dangling on these white blood cells
running around your body there's
trillions of them in your bloodstream
and lymphatic system each of them is a
complicated organic molecule twisted in
a funky shape and each of them serves as
a unique portrait of some particular
foreign agent antibodies make reliable
detect
of viruses and other foreign lumps of
protein because for any given virus
there's going to be only one antibody
that exactly dovetails with it
some small fraction are inherited from
the womb the body makes the rest but how
do you make a cellular database of
foreign dangers that you've never
encountered here's what we're talking
about the future I mean this is the
future this is your body predicting what
is gonna see before it's ever seen it in
other words how does the body know what
chickenpox looks like before it ever
gets chickenpox under its skin and the
answer is a really interesting mechanism
that biologist Gerald Edelman described
as a genetic jungler like everything
else in a cell the exact shape of the
protein dangling from a lymphocyte is
determined genetically but unlike the
stable genes that are in say the nucleus
or the membrane the the genes for a
lymphocytes receptor that antibody is
prone to shuffle itself during cell
reproduction it's basically kind of a
faulty genetic system but the good part
of this built-in randomizer is that each
of these billions of lymphocytes
initially produced by the body wears a
different chemical lure on its surface
so even if a chickenpox virus has never
got in your bloodstream before there's
probably a white blood cell in there
already with a protein to match that's
how the immune system knows what a
chicken pox virus looks like before it
gets to you now
when the gene jungler produces an
antibody that looks too similar to the
hosts own body the antibodies rejected
is useless like the antibody art
that is too similar to the social body
is also useless at least we think so in
the 21st century when we really need to
be thinking outside of ourselves to keep
pace with all this stuff that's coming
down the pike if you want art like
antibodies our diversity agents artists
online manipulate digital and social
codes to make art the way the immune
system manipulates genetic code to make
antibodies and like the immune systems
polymorphously perverse antibody
duction it gives art a kind of quirky
and and prophetic vision something
that's unlikely to emerge from a bunch
of think tanks and ran trying to figure
out what the future is going to bring
which is sometimes why they bring over
like Hollywood writers and novelists and
you know people science fiction authors
to help them figure out what's coming
down the pike the misuse of genetic code
which might prove lethal elsewhere in
the body allows the immune system to
anticipate shapes as never encountered
artists similarly are wrongheaded they
misuse computer genetic social codes to
reveal the ways in which society is
being shaped by new technological and
political forces well okay that's the
perversion side what about the execution
side and let me yeah when it comes to
executing code especially the DNA that
controls their reproduction white blood
cells are trigger-happy if any of these
proteins ever connects with something
that actually fits that is like you've
got a an antibody that matches
chickenpox and actually comes in contact
with something that looks like
chickenpox or is chickenpox the match
turns that lymphocyte into a chemical
warning beacon it just alerts everything
in its area and given its in the
bloodstream pretty soon the whole body
knows about it even more importantly
that activated like blood cell does the
sort of microbial equivalent of going
into heat it just makes an incredible
number of copies of itself and I have
the statistics here a stimulated
lymphocyte creates new antibodies at the
rate of 10,000 molecules per cell per
second that's 10,000 per cell per second
and that creates a systemic change in
the entire lymphatic and circulatory
system so at the beginning of an
infection your bloodstream may contain
only handful of antibodies to counter
chickenpox but afterward within a few
days billions of chickenpox antibodies
are flowing through your bloodstream so
to execute again
in the world of genetic or computer code
means to turn the potential power of
instructions into the actual power
behavior but there's a lot of codes at
play in both immunological and social
bodies the immune system X
it's code when it recognizes invasion of
the body by foreign code like a virus
digital art executes its code when it
recognizes invasion of the social body
by codes that appear foreign or harmful
whether their culture illegal or social
however there's a little more
complication to that and Joe lenity you
want to go into on the edge so it would
seem from what John just said that
anybody's and viruses operate by
comparable mechanisms and they do and
maybe they just happen to be on opposite
sides of the skin or blood barrier but
they have a more important difference
than that than location and that is
antibodies are part of a larger
ecosystem the ecosystem of your body to
which they are accountable while viruses
are accountable only to themselves this
makes antibodies a much more interesting
metaphor for art of the Internet age
antibodies work in a network of life
they are mechanisms for envisioning and
populating the body with alien forms in
other words they occupy a liminal space
between self and other not entirely
under the control of either basically
you could say they surf the immune
network so in order for antibodies to
maintain this function they need to
maintain their independence so they are
not subservient to any kind of top-down
command and control system from the body
that was the old view of how the immune
system works but a Nobel Prize winner
actually has suggested that the immune
system actually works much more like a
network which is a very interesting way
of thinking about it and it turns out
that this network is not a top-down
system but rather a bottom-up bottle
that it works by selection rather than
by instruction the bone marrow produces
a million varieties of antibodies 99% of
which will never serve the body at all
it's only when in anybody courses
through the blood stream and it happens
to match up a foreign antibody that it
reproduces wildly and counters the
pathogens invasion in the short term and
it lingers in the bloodstream as somatic
memory in the long term the somatic
memory in the bloodstream we think is
like cultural memory in the social body
artists produce the kind of a
fact a system change that produces a
kind of cultural memory that we remember
in the larger social body so similarly
we don't think that the NEA should have
a top-down approach to artists either
that they should tell what artists
should paint or code or write like the B
cells in the immune systems frontline
artists are better positioned than any
centralized establishment to spot and
confront pressing cultural issues
whether their technological like gene
harvesting or legal like music piracy or
personal like online intimacy dispersed
across scientific labs and virtual
communities and street corners rather
than cosseted in studios and concert
halls artists represent a kind of
grassroots defense against the invasion
of cultural memes of course even a
grassroots defense astilbe defense a
truism that would seem to cast doubt on
the immune system as a kind of metaphor
for this newfound proactive power that
our Tweel's
in the Internet age after all isn't much
of the motivation for art's eruption
outside of galleries and museums
precisely to avoid them at the
emasculation of power that attends its
circumscription by the white cubes of
art aren't today's creative thinkers
targeting the stock exchange global
surveillance networks and restrictive
copyright laws precisely because they
think these are unhealthy institutions
that need attacking rather than healthy
institutions that need defending well
this is a reasonable objection and to
answer this requires a little bit more
nuanced look at the immune system it
turns out that natural antibodies like
components of many complex adaptive
systems work to keep a system in balance
with its entire environment not just
itself no mammal would ever have evolved
without some means of maintaining a
balance of power between self and other
and over the past 500 million years
immune systems have endowed vertebrate
metabolism with just enough stability
for their populations to Co evolve into
complex and variegated Ecology's
internally and externally for healthy
organisms this has often met disarming
malignant invaders in the for example in
the case of smallpox or malaria but in
some occasions it means welcoming them
into a relationship with the host and as
you probably know this mitochondria is a
foreign agent it has different DNA than
the rest of your body
and e-coli is also a foreigner that your
body tolerates in some kind of symbiotic
relationship so the other is also within
in many ways and helps us to survive
this encounter with other nYSSA's
healthy for the entire ecosystem it is
not a colonial mission to diminish other
nacelle side the body the immune system
is the aperture the valve that opens or
closes the body to the rest of the
microbial world as art opens or closes a
valve to the rest of a technological
political social world there are times
however when the animal by-products of
evolution are unsustainable when an
organisms metabolism is out of balance
with its environment and perhaps
shouldn't survive at least in its
current form indeed sometimes the body
defend itself all too well at which
point the immune systems mission of
defending the body is no longer
warranted when the body's intolerance of
other nests that no aliens cross the
skin barrier when the flow of
information across the immune aperture
gets squeezed to a trickle the immune
system can turn on its own hosts in
biology this condition is called
autoimmunity the organism quite
literally no longer recognizes itself
and if antibodies challenge the body's
own tissues instead of the foreign
agents in systemic autoimmune disorders
like lupus the antibodies target the
entire body in in other autoimmune
responses they target specific other
areas for example in Sarah ants
psoriasis it's the skin and type 1
diabetes it's the pancreas in multiple
sclerosis it's the nerves and rheumatoid
arthritis it's the bone joints but
interestingly epidemiologists have noted
an inverse relationship
between infectious disease and
autoimmune disorders in cultures where
smallpox and malaria is rampant
autoimmune diseases are rare
while in those with relatively flute
with relatively few external scourge as
the immune system appears more likely to
target its own host it is as though the
immune system expects a steady diet of
other nests of foreignness from the
external environment and if it doesn't
find enough other nasai dydt will
actually turn inside to look for it now
contemporary human bodies are more or
less stable products of evolution so far
we think in cases of autoimmunity among
human populations can result in tragic
suffering or at best annoyance or
discomfort these are not very pleasant
situations but this situation is not as
clear for our social body at the
beginning of this 21st century which by
many accounts is wildly out of balance
with its environment from the overreach
of corporate interest to the relentless
proliferation of Technology to the
reckless provocation of global climate
change and needs to be drastically
readjusted if this is true then art can
act as an antibody and still assault its
own culture step back to view these
diametrically opposed opposed conditions
artist defender or artist attacker step
back from a more expansive perspective
the yes man's Georg project this is the
project that got them an invitation to
represent the WTO uses the perversity of
Reem Weaver and the execute ability of
the web´s domain name system by
basically buying up gat org and posing
as WTO representatives so by using that
domain name system it undermines the
credibility of the World Trade
Organization as we've just as I
mentioned before you could say that the
yes-men but the WTO that that the
yes-men might say for example that the
WTO is an internal Menace contributing
to an unhealthy social body or they
could say that the WTO is an external
threat to a healthy social body that
it's a corporate giveaway that seeks to
undermine adjust society via unnatural
technologies or unnatural economic
controls from the standpoint of
coevolution of an organism with its
environment it ultimately doesn't matter
whether a threat is internal or external
for systems far from equilibrium the
distinction between self and other
breaks down anyways what is important is
how art goes about challenging these
threats so I'd like to talk for a moment
about this double-edged character of
antibodies and how art of the Internet
age has a similar double-edged character
it can defend or a sale its hosts
depending on the context so I think it's
easy to get scared if you are at a
position of power and you realize that
all an artist has to do is register a
domain name and they can sync your stock
market price
you know overnight but even when art
challenges its own society the
accountability differs from the
accountability of direct political
action whether that's from the inside or
the outside a social body like a human
body isn't just a free-for-all
it's a complex set of feedback
mechanisms and a political activist
whether her weapon is a pistol or a
press conference with bad politics is
going to wreak suffering and havoc on
the world artists on the other hand have
to be free to explore unconventional
untested even dangerous values with
impunity so how do you let them do that
well you don't hand them a pistol if
anything this makes artists more
accountable than antibodies because they
have to exercise care for the social
body even when they attack it in return
for this artistic license that allows a
creator to explore risky themes that
crater has to take care to undermine
rather than over power to impose
questions rather than impose answers and
for its part society has to come back
and tolerate a perverse multitude of
artistic and
and directions just like the biological
body tolerates this perverse alien forms
produced by antibodies like antibodies
the artists are inefficient drain on the
body's resources like antibodies the
arts are worth it the job of an artist
like that of an antibody is to conjure
possible threats to that body real or
imagined while this conjuring may not
put the body directly at risk
nevertheless reactionary impulses are
likely to see these conjuring zazz more
dangerous than they really are not just
because they threaten life and limb they
often don't but because they threaten
something about the status quo it's
unjust or it's hidden by ideological
blinders but that's why the yes men call
their work identity correction in their
words honest people impersonate big time
criminals in order to publicly humiliate
them targets are leaders and big
corporations who put profits ahead of
everything else alright that's not to
say artists can't do damage so there is
a kind of artistic license and an
expectation of accountability but the
damage that art does stems from
revelation rather than ruin there's
nothing artistic about Union Carbide
which is the company that before doubt
bought it secret decision to test
unproven technologies at a gas plant in
Bhopal okay so 1984 15,000 people died
hundreds thousands injuries nothing
artistic about that intervention but
when the yes men hijacked that domain
gow ethics to publicize the earth sets
pathology it wasn't just an innocuous
prank either you know two billion
dollars in market value lost in a matter
of minutes
that was an artistic victory a
revelation not a direct attack so much
as a revelation of GAO's tenuous
standing given its history of unethical
and unsustainable business practices it
was an other position that the social
body had as yet been unprepared to
accept now the yes men also attacked the
World Trade Organization in its policies
well does that mean the September 11th
al-qaeda attacks and the World Trade
Center were
a work of art because they revealed the
vulnerability of us hegemony in an
increasingly globalized world well a
couple artists thought so karl-heinz
Stockhausen who recently died and Damien
Hirst who unfortunately still alive
thought so
applauding the 9/11 terrorist acts as
quote the greatest work of art ever but
the revelation produced by the
destruction of the Twin Towers took the
form of certainty
whatever confusion immediately ensued
there was nothing curious or intriguing
about 2,700 bodies burned and crushed to
death artists should not be allowed this
kind of power and Stockhausen and Hearst
both apologize later
for their appalling category error
likewise Joe Davis's info gene that's
his ecoli that he brought up there with
a picture in it would cease to be art if
his genetic intervention turned e.coli
into a vector for anthrax indeed some
critics of experimenters like Davis
rightly in my mind questioned the
accountability of the techniques of
genetic engineering whether in the hands
of biotech art or artists in contrast
the recent jailing of artist Stephen
Kurtz some of you may know held without
charge on terrorist charges basically
because he had a couple petri dishes in
his room reminds us the importance of
protecting artists and their research
into avenues that are conceptually
dangerous if not physically so even the
law eventually came to this conclusion
in Kurtz's cases the authorities had to
end up dropping every charge against him
except mail fraud so I think that there
is a double-edged sword here but somehow
the two edges seem to kind of balance
each other and as long as we accept that
balance then art will continue to serve
us by challenging us
so we've argued so far that the
influence of today's art may extend
outside the art world and infiltrate
court cases chat rooms bedrooms our
current research into connected
knowledge suggests that within
indigenous cultures this influence
extends even father into influence over
the body the family the community and
the ecosystem that's a particular kind
of technological reach that our
technologies don't necessarily have or
not in the same way but they certainly
do reach into that place yet in both of
these cases we're talking about
influence rather than power we're
talking about not damage but we're
talking about revelation it's very
important to maintain that distant that
distinction right now if the work that
we're looking at is any indication the
work that you've seen and we've only
shown you a couple of examples there are
far more examples in the book and you
can take a look at that or you can ask
us questions about that other examples
but they're really there's a tremendous
amount of artistic practice of the kind
that we're talking about and if that's
any indication of where we are headed in
the future and it's actually very
interesting indication in any case if
that's any indication then we are really
on the verge of a transformation from a
vertical hierarchy of control of power
of top-down to a kind of horizontal web
of life you know art on the edge shows
us that whether we make this transition
depends on whether or not we can
reignite this creative potential of this
horizontal movement we can reignite it
in our children in our students and our
neighbors and our colleagues in our
community and in all the beings around
us without which our intelligence and
our living networks are drastically
diminished we are right now on the edge
and the tipping point is before us the
question is which way will we lean thank
you
[Applause]
couple questions already
that was fast you want to leave
something live flashing and ladies
dicing my slice you're longing outside
or something um cherlene when you
started you mentioned that part of the
sort of art environment that's going on
is there's less public support of art at
least in North America I can't tell
whether you thought that was a good idea
or bad idea because you're sort of
implying it in a sense it's a good idea
because it pushes artists out into the
world they go onto the web which is very
low threshold environment to do stuff
where you don't have to you know build
forever or they wind up out at Burning
Man where they just do it basically for
each other and and it's it's more than a
hobby mode in a way so is a place like
Europe which has a lot more public
support of the Arts are are they over
civilized in this respect I think that's
an interesting debate and discussion and
I think that I would turn to a third
alternative for that not the u.s. which
under funds the art or Europe which I
don't know if it over funds the art but
in both clay in both cases the public
support for art is coming from large
institutions like governments like
corporations basically it's sort of
coming from a top-down anyway and even
if you say well they can give money but
they can't they can't really determine
the content of the art that's left to
the artists or the artists organizations
themselves even in those cases it really
isn't public support for the Arts a
better case would be for example in
Papua New Guinea where art is created by
many more people in the community
because they don't have a lot of
entertainment to take their time away
and sort of feed them they produce art
for each other in fact in in New Guinea
they have a form of art called Milan
gone it is a production of textile or
sculpture and when you produce this
textile or sculpture which are really
producing as kinship relationships
relationships between people and so when
you talk about public support for the
art you also
much of the public is engaged in a kind
of art practice of one form or another
and you're producing a little bit more
than just objects you're producing
something a little bit more profound so
I think the model that we would look
toward is not so much large institutions
pouring lots of money into the arts but
a much larger awareness of the
importance of Arts across the culture
and many more people engaging in
producing as well as consuming and maybe
those producing consuming dichotomies
are a little bit problematic anyway but
basically involved in the arts would be
a much better solution I think here's a
question from Alexander Rose er did you
have a point of that drawing except
maybe to chime in that there was a study
recently of the UK gets a lot of US
American artists salivate when we see
the UK because they have so much money
flowing the arts there was a study
recently in Scotland that 90% of that
money went to administration that sounds
worthy of some artwork right there
[Laughter]
Alexandra Rose's question is does this
mean the reorienting of the truth by
groups like Fox News is art
[Music]
actually this is a really good question
and it's one that I asked my students
when I put up the two Dow sites the sort
of one of my students said oh well
digital art is just self-expression
using digital tools isn't it like we're
all digital we're expressing ourselves
and that means we're being creative and
I said okay let's look about let's let's
look at some examples of self-expression
so I said okay here's the yes-man and
here is here's ya this is Dow because
that's got the ethics on there and this
is the yes-men site some sometimes a
little bit hard to tell and I said are
both of these art they're both kind of
self-expression in a certain kind of way
so which of these is art or are they
both art and the conversation that we
had in class was a question of social
accountability in some ways and what the
students basically decided once they
talked about the HU commercials and that
kind of media campaign is they said that
well this is trying to tell us something
but it's telling us the opposite of
what's really going on and we're not
really sure that's art so that
revelation is really significant a
symptom that's true of antibodies well
and in in the book wait wait a minute
are you saying that artists never lie
never never they never lie well it's a
there is the idea that for example
novelists which is a feel like come from
lie to tell it a different kind of truth
but the idea is that you're revealing
something that we need to know you're
revealing something that we need to to
see to understand the world that we live
in rather than hiding things from us for
example sort of hiding what is really
going on in the Bhopal situation what is
really going on in terms of personal
responsibility the hiding of something
is not art even if what you're showing
is an attempt to hide something else so
are the students concluded that that's
not really a form of art but you may
have a different conclusion
in terms of the two of these frankly I
don't find advertisement really tells me
much of what I want to know and I when I
see advertisement I usually apply the
180 degree rule so for example my
favorite advertisements are car
advertisements because car
advertisements show beautiful natural
settings only one car on the road
usually it's a dirt road and it's it's
quite lovely the air is clean as no
global warming and in fact cars do the
opposite so if it seems to me that if
you need to advertise then somehow the
word out there isn't very good about you
anyway otherwise you wouldn't be
spending five million dollars trying to
say something if your product is already
doing it so I don't I I have a real
problem with advertising and that it
doesn't work for me I don't I don't find
that it works for me no I don't let's
look at mr. Toscani here I don't let me
see if I can bring I haven't seen an
advertisement that that does that for a
photo shop curse but maybe there is some
I haven't seen it yet bravia um I
haven't seen it I've seen it and it's a
ok let's one step at a time
this is a photograph by Oliviero Toscani
the Benetton photographer well-known for
promulgating the United Colors of
Benetton campaign what most people
especially in America for some reason
don't know is that his campaign was
always gritty in one way or another yes
you may know the sort of you know
multiracial people kissing on the sides
of buses but you might not know about
the beef hearts labelled white black
yellow or the bloody Yugoslavian uniform
and so forth and we're talking about
these literally you know in billboards
on the street and so forth here is one
of the few people I think who've managed
to make an inroad into advertising and
turn it into a form of art but you
followed up with something Kevin about
the this does nothing to do with his
clothes then that into with Benetton
clothes right
which of course you know again it has
nothing to do if I'm interested in
buying clothes from Benetton this is not
telling me anything about the clothes
for example where it's made who's making
it how old the kids are who are making
it if it's kids where the products come
from is it organic or not you know all
these kinds of things that I really want
to know about the products I'm buying I
don't really find out from
advertisements so maybe that's why Evert
iseman doesn't interest me that what
information is giving me is not what I
want to know now maybe advertisements
doing something different then telling
me something about well as this does let
me step into that one of the things I
got from hanging out with Brian Eno's
talked a couple times in this series is
that yeah art is about society which is
what you guys have been mainly working
on tonight but also art is about our and
artists are always intensely aware of
you know a dialogue or argument they're
having with either their predecessors or
the contemporaries and part of what
makes advertising work as a medium is
that a lot of advertising is about
advertising and it assumes the knowledge
in the audience of nuances and jokes and
references and all this kind of stuff
which is very similar to the kind of
things that you know Andy Warhol is
doing what he's referring to all of his
predecessors so that kind of dialogue
that very nuanced fashion oriented a
sophisticated dialogue is part of the
same story of society checking out new
ways to think about things at the edge
of how subtle can you be does that make
sense
but I think there's also been a break
and it's it's a break that we're trying
to mark with our book and our thinking
here in in the 20th century this
solipsism became so extreme that art
became about itself very quickly and
there was really you know there had
artists like Joseph Kossuth who whatever
69 wrote something called art after art
after philosophy in which he claimed
that all art was essentially about
itself
and every piece of art was a new
definition of art and that was fine for
a while but no what happened is that all
of those inbred references became so
arcane that you had to you know go
around to galleries and Chelsea every
few weeks in order to understand a
particular
and I think what we're looking at is the
explosion of our outside of that white
cube outside of that restricted kind of
nursery if you will so that yeah there
are references to culture there but when
you see the Star Wars movie of DCs s
code it's a lot more people to get that
one than get that you know Warhol was
making a reference to Basquiat who is
making a reference to Co suit now every
kind of performer calls themselves an
artist I mean the singer a
country-western singer man this is the
art except for the one formally known at
November okay who got his name back I
think now he's formally known as the
artist he was called the artist for a
while
it sounds like part of what you guys are
probing around for here is people who
don't even know they're artists right
and don't think of themselves as artists
are doing what you consider to be an art
function in the world is that correct
that's a good part of what we discovered
when we were looking online and we were
looking offline and we were looking at
creative activity is that a lot of
people who we thought were artists
didn't think of themselves as and we're
not working in traditional art this is a
bad thing happened if you call them an
artist do they get self-conscious
freeing not everyone is comfortable with
the term as we are mm-hm
as we mentioned I mean the whole
question that we had to begin with is
whether art was even useful at all as a
category whether we should continue to
use the word whether people should
continue to practice art what it was
about these were some of the questions
that first informed our work and we saw
that there was a great sort of
uneasiness among artists largely because
art had become so emasculated when it's
only talking about itself it's not doing
anything in the world and therefore
they're not interested and that's what
we discovered and we were interested in
the kind of art that is not talking
about itself but talking about the world
that we live in because our world is
really in a kind of a precarious
position right now and talking you know
talking within a white cube is not gonna
help us get out of it according to some
of the people that we're looking at
whose work we're looking at notice that
in the news today was that they got some
glow-in-the-dark cats in Korea which are
going to be used for genetic research
which is great this art caller's an
artist about 10 years ago who made some
glow-in-the-dark
fish which are illegal in California for
no good reason
but anyway I'm sure you can go to Nevada
I got a goal in the dark fish and
sneaking across the border but this is a
nice case of since you know an artist
really really jamming ahead without
anybody's permission and doing the
things that all my fellow
environmentalists knew was profoundly
evil and dangerous and was probably bad
for the fish and and and in and just why
not did it and put it out there and I
guess you buy these straight and they
freaked out the Californians that's
usually worth doing and now in the when
they glow that our cats come along we're
kind of ready for them
[Music]
the artist that you're talking about is
Eduardo Koch aha and what do you know
about it because I know this is real
hearsay I'm well okay where to start
with that one um
Eduardo let's say I think I have an
image of him around here somewhere one
of these was his antibody there we go so
this is Eduardo Koch's installation
Genesis which is shown I think what
Isaiah 2006 was the most recent
exhibition nearby and I might be wrong
about that it was also shown in Montreal
it's been shown all over the world it is
a series of of bacteria that have been
encoded with the phrase let man have
dominion over the birds and beasts in
other words the the very beginning or
one of the beginning phrases from the
Bible and Koch has made a career out of
tickling the fancies of gallery goers
and of you know the newspapers and
reporters and so forth but ultimately I
think you have to ask how how deep that
investigation is mm-hmm and whether it's
simply provoking for the sake of
provoking or whether there's something
more that's revealed in the process and
there are there are it's hard to tell
the difference
well sometimes it is but that's what to
me makes a difference between a good
artwork and a bad artwork we may be
defining our differently than we've
defined it in the 20th century but that
doesn't mean in my mind that there is a
difference between good and bad well now
this particular installation looks
rather gorgeous d'arco me oh okay is it
okay if it's beautiful another question
I'll let Jelena know we have debates
about this I think beauty is very
important it's critical I don't know why
I don't I I I think that many of us
respond to beauty and different forms of
beauty all the time in our lives I don't
think it's very been very well
articulated even the sort of history of
aesthetics doesn't talk about it in a
way that makes sense to me
but I do think that we respond to beauty
I don't think necessarily that when my
students are trying to paint beautiful
pictures that they're that their sense
of beauty is very well developed I think
that beauty always surprises us for
example I look to nature as an example
often when I'm trying to figure these
things out and in nature I see beautiful
things and they're almost always
unexpected I can't tell what it's going
to be until I see it and when I see it
something remarkable happens whereas in
a media world what is beautiful is often
for told for example what a beautiful
woman looks like is often scripted by
all the media images of what a beautiful
woman should look like so if she's too
overweight she's not beautiful if she's
too tall she's not all these things so
media scripts our sense of beauty so
much over and over again and so does art
that it's hard to really get that sense
of like oh that must be loosening with
this bottom-up web that we're in the
thick of for it so you know mainstream
media are struggling to keep up with all
of the weirdness which is percolating up
out of this trillions of antibodies and
presumably
agreed-on ideas of beauty or one of the
things get lost in that process yes well
I think that's sort of true but I don't
know for example that our book has a lot
of images of things that are beautiful
however it was important to us that it
was a beautiful book
because aesthetics matters to me but I I
don't think that that's the only thing
that matters to me in looking at art I
don't think it's the only criteria and I
don't I think that for example for
example I think that nature does beauty
a lot better than artists do in most
cases I just think that you know some
vistas some you know sometimes it's it's
small things on the ground sometimes I
live in Maine I live by a lake every
time I wake up and the Sun hits the
trees and the snow or the grass
differently it's gorgeous it's beautiful
it's unexpected and I've never seen any
painting that does it justice or any
photograph or anything that that does
the sort of play justice let me just
give you one reason why because nature
is profoundly interactive okay this
media is interactive maybe we here maybe
we touch maybe we see but we don't taste
this stuff we don't enter into it it's
not three-dimensional I mean we try I
mean nature has such a communication
with us it's so interactive and it's so
constantly moving and changing that the
depth of an experience in nature is much
deeper and so if you for example look at
recent research has come out for example
last child in the woods suggests that
human beings young people children who
don't have enough contact with nature
end up with all kinds of severe social
problems end up disconnected end up with
really not as intelligent because their
intelligence isn't as stimulated as it
is by these technologies as it is by the
natural world so the intelligence that
I'm talking about which is network does
not just network with other human beings
it's network with other beings of all
kinds with trees with birds with rocks
with water these are all beings that you
can communicate with and some cultures
still know how to do that when I went
back to Maine I told my children we
don't know how to do that all the
animals here the rocks the trees think
we're done because we no longer talk to
them we only talk to ourselves when
we're talking about the white box of art
and humans talking to themselves and art
talking about art we're talking about
that kind of embed autoimmune problem
that we don't really seek other nacelle
or and we can't communicate with it and
it doesn't communicate to us but having
been in Maine for a while I can tell you
tree stories if you ask me
about communication between humans and
non-humans which is what the shaman
always does on the edges of their own
cultures so I think the communication
the interactivity we need is much deeper
than what this stuff promises as
interactivity you will now go out and
run around the block let me end with a
properly dangerous question since
dangers what this is all about you guys
been married how long never not great
never married you've been parents for
how long how long going on ten years ten
years okay what I'd love to know is on
the subject of tonight what do you guys
have disagreements about and how do you
manage those disagreements and how much
time do we have fun you know a couple
hood is a paradox you're always playing
against that that you're absolutely won
and you're absolutely not won and when
you're probing deep like you're trying
to do with understanding art here you
must be going in and out of agreement
and disagreement on a number of things
John for ironically I think that it's
the the collaboration on something
intellectual or aesthetic like the like
this you know book and so for our
research is the easiest part of our
relationship like the hardest part is
you know I'm working on the Curie
keyboard and Jillian's like okay we're
gonna learn the Dvorak keyboard we are
okay so I spent a summer learning little
taps on it because so anyway so then you
know a few months later I'm going back
to the QWERTY keyboard uh-huh we are
yeah and then tails that pales in
comparison to the struggles of of
raising children together and we I think
that any parents who really are both
engaged in that process have the hardest
time because somehow we expect two
people alone disconnected from the rest
of society with grandparents in
different time zones to somehow work out
how to raise
children together and we make it a
little harder for ourselves by
eliminating some of those those
conveniences of television and video
games and these other forms of
interactivity that are perhaps less
immediately useful to children we don't
religiously I tried to turn on the TV
this morning while we were finishing up
this presentation so my kids could watch
TV for 10 minutes or 15 minutes and my
son said do we have to watch TV and this
is someone we don't have a TV at home so
this was supposed to be his big thrill
San Francisco where they have TV right
not in Maine where we have a lake but my
son is also very interested in
advertisement he mimics it wherever he
can he's got a really big kick about
coca-cola and McDonald's and that's
because when we first went to Maine we
my son was four my daughter was two we
stopped at a McDonald's right near her
friendlies we went into the friendlies
and didn't go to McDonald's and my son
said he's four what's that why does it
have a big M what's going on there and
John turned around and said oh we're
going into friendlies that's me knees
all the people that Big M you see all
the people there really mean the food's
really lousy they're very rude and
because my son never eats fast food for
a year and a half in Maine he believed
that and then one day he had a playdate
and they took him to McDonald's and he
came how many said a Jewish I'm not mom
I'm goo ish Jewish I went to McDonald's
today and I said well yeah how was it
he's like well they weren't really that
mean and he said and I ate some french
fries I said well how were they he said
well they were okay but I didn't eat the
hamburgers so he's kind of still
struggling with that with that whole
thing as well I wanted to say just about
one thing that we're struggling with and
that is that co-parenting if anyone ever
tried co-parenting we started off equals
we were together 17 years before having
children so this was a great big bomb I
think Adrienne Rich said having children
is a time bomb in a relationship it is
trying to parent equally is really very
difficult and I realize that the reason
they have gender roles seed so that you
don't have turf wars and I've been
studying animals true I've been setting
animals an animal sort of arrangements
like for example wolves have really
interesting animal arrangements and it
turns out that they actually separate
different turfs to reduce the amount of
turf wars they have so that having
different turf not necessarily gender
roles specifically but having different
turfs is very good so I think in the
general question of couples and getting
along
one of the major insights recently is
separate our turfs and not don't overlap
too much and this book was a major
overlap make sure you had to balance
that with a fair amount of it you have
to know where your edges are really yes
anything else that I want to finish up
with us anything recall the night well
there was a question I think that Kevin
had raised earlier in the night and was
about was about something about what
what brand of art makes the most
creative stew and am i right in thinking
we all decided it was a stew art brand
happy birthday
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]